see look closely these glasses are
monogrammed is the letter T because I
bought them for my brother Tim like two
or three years ago Christmas and they
didn't get delivered in time and so I
just kept them Tim here's what could
have been
I got any regrets help you know now you
know your life is different now welcome
to another video in which I comment on
your comment let's jump right into it
let's start over on Iran I feel
pressured to post there on a daily basis
doctor person do remember two realities
on the way new friends and comments on
my social media platforms that grace the
crap on the Muslims it's great family
basically I just sort of say a bunch of
random things about a person's username
and we all get there eventually doctor
person more like lawyer robot human rude
rptr season 10 looks interesting yes
everyone is live looking for their lives
and lips became further muscle live we
still don't know if Hanna memmer married
days at least by my eyes I leave more
like days and released it's how I feel
like every time I go out of house
through a grace I was on the phone with
my friend today and she was talking and
I was giving her monotone answers and
she said you know who you sound like
right now at grace Helbig and naturally
I got both excited and confused so I was
like why is that and she said because
you are so mama toned and uninterested
and I said oh not true and idk why I
felt the need to share that with you but
I did so you are welcome wet face emoji
Wow thank you for this anecdote it's
always nice to know that people think my
brand is genuinely monotone and
uninterested
I did take a theater class in college
once and I think my acting instructor
would be so upset but that's the brand
I've cultivated hey subscribe be on a
car pee a cube and I got a car pee at my
Briana's car to you on that pee on your
car clean your territory you got that
Kia Soul for a reason super great where
are your ugh oh yeah this is left on a
photo of me chugging Gatorade in the
wilderness and the thing that is not
pictured in this photo are an actual
pair of forest green eggs I will in the
wild you can take the girls Jersey but
the Jersey girl is going to take the
eggs with her everywhere she goes yeah
let's go really great the main
difference if I may with more like
racing names are going to Montreal Just
for Laughs you are in Montreal and want
to come to us too sentiments of haha
from Sunday night look at our social
media profiles there will be information
about tickets there you have a great
quality hangover outfit thank you very
feel big ah Onan way too hot on my
excitement
Rosella wearing and I don't know
sweatshirt undone forget that I made
this picture for you guys and I love it
so much that I was recently thinking
about possibly doing some other merge
which I don't know on it let me know you
think I don't know merge is something
you would be interested in you can use
the commenting section down below to do
so with that spoken word I didn't spoken
word poetry look out Hamilton
WX destroy our new version of us
destroyer more like just destroyer you
seem awful good grades absolutely no one
cared
Wow but there's some fiber in your being
I cared enough to tweet this out with
perfect grammar and punctuation
so X destroyer yes I'll go to prom with
you Loie anger boomerang more like low
angles high dismissals of like on photo
human boot if my tampon just fell out
wow this is something I relate to and
also that woman has an amazing but
Bethenny we know Florida remembers me
when Bethenny we know for what I said to
you is girl for this is the magazine I
guess because I'm not forgetting anymore
do great love this film dirty thirty
movie hard ptomaine time great ally when
someone tells you that they haven't
watched it yeah at jawline gotta cut a
[ __ ] that hasn't watched dirty dirty
movie gonna do a movie calm or watch it
where it's available great a bug now
let's go to Mary Lou when you're here
you're family beater rust removers to
where indeed are us more like oh man
that girl was so dry would you had to
have sex a fairy you were probably like
oh what's what's going on so Regina D
Vera what no you look great
as a guy I'm glad my tampons don't fall
out yeah isn't that amazing that you
have to deal with that every thirty days
Wow light of that perhaps you should
take an effort to support women's health
Wow leading heartening for today leading
are more like leaving sharks humid word
you are a funny girl keep up the good
work grace okay so it seems that my
mother has created another YouTube
account because I have not returned her
phone calls hi mom oh wow thank you for
your positive support I love you let's
work on a new icon for your YouTube
channel
okay BB hey bb more like are you okay
bro eat my whole I think I'm gonna begin
well there you go
that's it for commenting on your
comments this week thank you so much for
leaving so many colorful comments on all
of my social media
platformed if you want to follow me
anywhere all the links in description
box below I'll just do a thumbs up if
you like commenting on this video and
the crunch of youtube channel click that
subscribe button and there's like a
little Bell thing you can click and it
gives you those cases when I upload a
video because I like to say that upload
Monday Wednesday and Friday we all know
that that's not true a little Bell thing
will help you know when I actually do it
add up health education Ivers my
dictation more like pap smear I should
get one personal health guru good OMG
grace your abs are so much lately I'm a
bit concerned harp face emoji I am too I
think I want to do what you do when you
get a pet you put a microchip in them so
if they get lost you can figure out
where they are so I think I'm going to
do that for myself so if I go too far
into nature you guys will be able to
really back in please dear cause I'm
getting too much vitamin D I think I'm
like happy make for good YouTube videos